absence de rendre pour personnes à
mobilité réduite des escaliers vite
inondées en cas de pluie pour arriver
sur les quais et depuis quelques mois le
guichet grands lignes fermées certains
usagers s'estime être laissés pour
compte
pour sortir de la gare c'est vraiment
pas pratique il ya des marches et l'adaf
passage là mais il ya des marges juste
derrière donc même pour les mamans avec
des poussettes bas on est obligé de les
aider pour passer ce qui est embêtant ce
pas pouvoir faire de cartes navigo ou
d'acheter des grandes lignes sur les
automates c'est assez compliqué faut
aller à saint quentin et se fermaient le
week-end donc du coup quand on travaille
la semaine réputé face à la situation
les mairies de maurepas la verrière et
l'encours et coignières lance une
pétition pour d'abord demandé le
prolongement de la ligne c du rer
jusqu'à coignières le syndicat des
transports d'ile-de-france le repousse
pour l'instant à 2019 les quatre élus
veulent également obtenir la mise aux
normes d'accessibilité de la station
avant 2015
ils se sont mis d'accord pour réaliser
les travaux de voirie en torrent la
station mais là encore aucun délai ne
semble fixée
nous on se préoccupe des aménagements
les communes sont mis d'accord les
travaux auront lieu le poncho l'air va
être doublé les accès routiers vont être
facilité tout ça sert à quoi si c'est
pour amener des gens dans une gare qui
reste dans un état de vétusté pareil
c'est une programmation qui prendra
plusieurs années dont les travaux ont
commencé
une première phase qui est prévu pour
s'échelonner sur les toutes prochaines
années
construite en 1977 edgar n'a fait
l'objet d'aucune rénovation importante
environ dix mille personnes prennent
quotidiennement le train de la verrière